folks have never achieved the level of
success that Barcelona did Barcelona in
09010 that kind of four-year run that
Guardiola had it's the greatest Club
sign ever I don't think anyone would
ever say the travel winning site even
though it's amazing for Man United fans
that wasn't the best site to ever come
out of Europe that wasn't that wasn't a
generational side it's one of them of
course it's a generation you believe
what you just said I don't think it is
it's not a generational side it is
and a lot of those players went on to
win another you were knocking at long
four five two to Dwight York and all
that
the philosophy of Johann kreifer and
getting messy to play as a false line
score in 91 goals and Academy unless you
carried my man he hasn't won a Champions
League without Messi yeah but yeah
a couple of areas but also peps gone
into a Barcelona side that was blessed
with Messi and Javi Iniesta and all that
you're going to buy a Munich in a one
team buy a Munich in one team League he
hasn't had to you know do it
all the time